the world of godzilla what is it and
when will it come out
a couple of pretty interesting questions
the title itself is self-explanatory it
is the world that godzilla lives in and
must include other monsters and guide
you as well
but well wait a minute isn't the monster
verse or toho godzilla's franchise
already there
what's the need for another world
another universe well here in this video
we will explain all there is to know
about this new concept and whether it
has launched itself into the movie
screens and if not will it come out soon
so let's get to it
what is the world of godzilla with the
cooperation of warner bros and legendary
pitchers the tentatively titled world of
godzilla is a proposed japanese and
american media franchise and [ __ ]
universe that will revolve around
godzilla and other toho characters and
will be a big part of the monster verse
or rather the most of us will be a part
of it
due to the conditions surrounding the
present contract between warner bros and
legendary pitchers it is expected to
begin somewhere around 2021 with films
shadowed to be released every two years
with the possibility of yearly releases
as well the goal of the cinematic
universe is to establish a long-lasting
universe that many participants can use
to express themselves creatively for a
long time
so does toho and legendary have a deal
so what are their plans after that after
2021 well they're considering a system
in which godzilla movies are released
every two years however there is a
preference for a yearly release if
possible the series is future and
subsequent advancements are extremely
cognizant of the shared universe method
godzilla mothra king ghidorah and other
monsters might all share a single world
view similar to how iron man the hulk
captain america can cross parts in a
marvel film each film is believed to be
a potential film production in which any
of them may play epinemous characters in
their own movies later on so this will
be sort of an mcu kind of a world but
with giant monsters and guide you
so if this were to come true then what
will be the main kaiju and will this
franchise include other monsters in it
like in a deal with other major monster
franchises like pacific rim for instance
which is owned by legendary pitchers and
warner bros well we will be closely
monitoring the situation and whenever
news come in it's gonna be here so yeah
what will be the main kaiju godzilla of
course since it's gonna be the namesake
of this universe and the main ones the
other ones which will share the touhou
kaiju timeline is mothra ghidorah rodan
and giras jet jaguar probably and there
will be movies or shows that will
include the titans of the monster verse
alongside the touhou kaiju as well and
as we said earlier pacific rim is owned
by legendary pitchers and if this
universe were to come to fruition then
slaaden the mega kai to the jaegers will
all appear in the same time together
alongside godzilla mothra and all
so another question is will this
franchise only be movies or will it be
included with anime comics series as
well well given the fact that the
monster verse has comics it has movies
like godzilla kong etc and comics such
as aftershock kingdom kong and dominion
this shared universe will have these
media as an intermediary for setting up
the timeline and missing plots for
upcoming big screen flicks and on the
other side toho which has movies such as
shin godzilla and anime like the ones of
godzilla singular point and with the
anime movie trilogy of godzilla earth
which are already there so such
directions could be undertaken for such
a massive scale project and now we come
to the right question when will this
universe come into the screens
well it isn't here already so we do have
to wait a while we have to wait because
of the dl touhou made with legendary
pictures which allowed for godzilla 2014
godzilla king of the monsters and
godzilla vs kong to happen but in the
meantime toho was also making shin
godzilla and the godzilla earth animated
film trilogy and also lately godzilla
singular point but nothing more
cinematic until the two production
companies deal expires in 2021. neither
touhou nor legendary pitchers have
mentioned anything about how to host
plan world of godzilla will come and how
it will affect legendaries most of us in
the future or even if there will be a
monster verse at all of the king kong
and godzilla's titanic battle
probably why there is so little news
about the next monster verse movie
because toho wants its own version of
the cinematic universe and its own
masters back into its fold so godzilla 3
son of calm and all those things have to
wait
so yeah that is all i have about the
world of godzilla and if there is more
info then do share it with us in the
comments section below anyway with that
we come to the end of the video do hit
that like button for support and
subscribe to be a part of the minecube
family and most of all smash the bell
icon for regular updates on new videos
right here on this channel till the next
one take care fam